thank you
okay so the Last of Us teaser trailer
has just dropped online and the stunning
show has a lot to impact from it
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down all the Easter eggs game
references and also things you missed to
talk about why we're so excited for the
show if you enjoyed the video please
click as the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel to
join our club without the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the trailer
[Music]
the roses have faded there's Frost at my
door the birds in the morning don't sing
anymore
okay so we opened with Joel being played
by Pedro Pascal over the top of the
teaser we can hear this song alone and
forsaken by Hank Williams and the
drifting Cowboys this song pulls
directly from the game and it's what we
hear when Jill and Ali crash in
Pittsburgh just after they're ambushed
[Applause]
this scene pops up towards the end of
the teaser and we can see as the pair
crash into a store now when initially
watching this I thought it might be a
day scene that we weren't privy to in
the original game The Source material
starts off from the perspective of
Joel's daughter Sarah on the night that
the first outbreak happened from here he
watches everything devolves into chaos
and we actually get some shots of this
in the trailer this includes Joel his
brother Tommy and Sarah all sat in a
truck as they try and escape the trailer
adds something that wasn't in the game
which is a plane crashing and we also
see Joel carrying her as he runs this
was pretty much how the game opened and
there's a big scene that happens right
after this between Joel and his daughter
that day she gifted him a watch which
gets broken during this escape and he
ends up wearing it for the rest of his
life we can actually see this early on
in the teaser and the costume design
looks perfect when we put it side by
side with the show looks like we're
getting a scene in which we see one of
the infected spring up and also the
moment when the truck crashes we get a
split second shot of Gabriel lunar in
the flames and we know that he's going
to be playing Tommy man was also a rider
in the Flames at one point and if this
is as impactful as the game then it's
gonna be a heartbreaking way to open the
series anyway back to the opening shot
and rather than it being pre-outbreak I
think this is definitely post this
appears to be the federal camp that we
pick up in after the time Jump and if
you look closely you can see Pedro's
hair is gray now similar to Joel's at
this stage in the game we see people
wearing bucket hats and the red
buildings also look similar how they
appeared in the original work next we
get to a sign which details the curfew
and in this early level there was lots
of talk about how they were sneaking
around outside of these hours in order
to initially catch Robert and then
smuggle out Ellie we then see a sign
below this talking about the cordyceps
infection and for those who haven't
played the games this is basically what
start the outbreak the parasite does
exist in the animal kingdom but it only
really infects insects and smaller
animals however the last of us had it
mutating so that it infected humans then
everything went worse and when Liz truss
got in charge now these symptoms include
coughing slurred speech muscle spasms
and also a mood change they tend to set
in within a couple of hours which is why
Jill and his partner test don't question
the reveal that comes with Ellie I know
there'll be some of you who haven't
played the game but it centers around
geola escorting her to a firefly Outpost
where they'll apparently be able to
create a cure from her blood Ellie is
the only person who's ever been found to
be immune to the cordyceps infection and
she's seen as Humanity's last hope you
see one of these Firefly signs being
covered up and they litter the game with
alien Joel Moving through different
cities as they try and get to where
they've hidden out they're basically a
rebel crew and we see their leader
Marlene later on in the teaser he's
holding her gut confirming that this
takes place early on in the game right
after Joel and Tess kill Robert I'm not
sure who the woman with her is as she's
a new creation for the show but this is
definitely Marlene at one point we get
what appears to be when the alarm sets
off with people being shot on the street
and the federal army going through it
bit by bit the first part of the trailer
seems to Center around escaping the
federal city which is what the early
part of the game does too I've been
playing through the PS5 remake recently
and they really captured the feel of it
including The Shining spotlights that
beam down once you make it past the wall
is starting to die and out in the
darkness The Whipper will scribe
darkness is falling the sky has turned
gray
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we see Joel alien Tess in a pipe and
when you're evading the beams you have
to crawl through these cracked streets
that lead down into sewers that are
littered with these later on we see Joel
smashing a federal agent's head in like
it's the like button I'm guessing this
happens just after Ellie is scanned
she's positive so it makes them draw
their weapons on her which is when Joel
kicks the crap out of one whilst Tess
shoots the other this is how they
discover she's immune and realize how
important she is once they make it past
here and further into the abandoned city
the next travel to the twin skyscrapers
that we see perfectly recaptured here
this was the shot that really made me
realize how much attention to detail
that they're painted the game and anyone
who's played it will instantly recognize
this location this is the place where
you really first start to encounter the
infected in other words some in the
run-ups with them before this it this
was really their natural habitat it's
full of clickers who are basically
people that are further along in the
infection the fungi has made them no
longer a fun guy and it's covered their
face leaving them blind which means they
now see with echo location one of the
final shots in the teasers ends on them
and they're one of the scariest monsters
ever created you will crap your pants if
you play the game at 3am with headphones
on and all the lights off I'm telling
you now next we get a shot that doesn't
pop up in the game looks like someone
watching over security footage and I
believe this might actually be Bill Bell
is going to be played by Nick Offerman
and I think this is gonna be perfect
casting Bill basically has his own town
that Joel and Ellie travel to in order
to get a car before they move on to
Pittsburgh he has booby traps set up
everywhere and it makes sense that he'd
be looking over footage though it's far
more populated than where he lives in
the game this makes me think that he
might be spying on a federal Camp rather
than looking over what's going on where
he lives Joe ends up getting caught in
one of his traps and it seems like
something similar is gonna be happening
here it's different in the game though
with him having to fight off the
infected whilst Ellie releases him but
we'll see what they do because it seems
like he's just getting stuck in a pit
now next we cut to an open field with
some bodies in it before we move to the
museum and here that Infamous clicker
clicking we watch as they move through
the displays which includes Civil War
era guns which are also parts of the
level layout
[Music]
this is your chance
from here we get several shots of cities
and also one that happens in the winter
this is a big part of the game and it's
basically where Ellie meets David I'll
talk about this later on but
interestingly it also looks like the DLC
is gonna be included in the series in
that we watched how Ellie got infected
and followed her and her friend Riley as
they moved through an abandoned Mall Ali
is gay and she and Riley ended up
realizing their feelings for each other
but they were sworn by the infected and
both got bitten the Merry-Go-Round is a
big part of this adventure and we see
that Riley's going to be played by storm
Reed I'm really excited to see how this
plays out and I'm glad the DLC wasn't
Left Behind
next we see a woman marching through the
streets no idea who this character is
and I've looked through the cast list
but can't see anyone that lines up with
her she's a brand new creation for the
show it looks like she's holed up in a
rebel City so this may be Pittsburgh
rather than being in the federal SWAT
team attire everyone seems to be wearing
what looks like normal clothes with some
scavenged helmet so I'm guessing she
might be the leader of the rebels might
also be setting things up for the second
game but yeah let me know below if you
know who this is now they do have an
armored truck with run on the front of
it which would be more in line with the
people from Pittsburgh later we're in
the teaser we see this truck chasing
three people and can see that one is
Ellie the other two look like they're
Henry and Sam making me think that this
is the night they go to escape
Pittsburgh and have to jump off the
bridge we also get a shot in which three
people are in a room together with a
woman sat down in a chair an explosion
goes off behind them and this scene
looks like it's brand new for the show
as it doesn't appear in the game I think
this woman can later be seen in the
trailer watching people flee and again
no idea who this is so let me know below
next we get Ellie's face covered in
blood and can tell from the background
that this is happening in the snow jewel
is comforting her and because of this
I'm guessing it happens just after she
kills David he was the leader of a group
of cannibals that Ellie came across in
the wilderness one whilst Joe was
resting up after being impaled by some
rebar I remember being agonizing
wondering if he was still alive as they
just drop you in it without telling you
and you have to play about an hour of
the game before you find out the whole
section is centered around Ellie being
captured by him and then she has to
escape and kill his forces whilst Joel
tries to get here really brilliant part
of the game and after the shot the
clicker we see Joe and Ellie standing
together I know people are kind of off
in the casting but I think she's
definitely got the attitude to pull
Ellie off and I'm really excited to see
where the series goes when it releases
in 2023 so overall really gripping
trailer that I think recaptures the game
perfectly as I mentioned earlier I have
been playing through the PS5 quote
unquote remake another price point of
that initially put me off I'm so glad I
got it because I forgot how perfect the
game really was still holds up today and
if they manage to recapture it live
action and I think it's going to be the
best video game adaptation of all time
isn't exactly hard but yeah I'm really
excited to see what they do with this
say who you can say
oh please understand
[Music]
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts on
it so make sure you comment below and
let me know if you are any competition
right now and giving away three copies
of dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
you make the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
heavy spoilers you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our Brighton of the House of the Dragon
episode 7 trailer which will be linked
on screen now we go over all the hidden
Easter eggs in it talk about how it
compares to the books and definitely
head over there right after this but out
the way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been poor I'll see in the
next one take care peace